this is a production of Cornell
University
okay so good to be here and so I haven't
made it earlier on so yeah I've been
working with the soul health program
with Harold been a perhaps twenty
something years and around the state in
the region a lot of people know me as
the soils guy so healthcare also peel
off stuff with water management other
people know me as the climate change
because I've also been doing that work
climate change in agriculture for the
last 20 years 25 years or so and you
know it's as particularly as this
interesting carbon farming's been
developing those two worlds have really
come together so this is really bringing
together soil health and what you've
been learning about that and talking
about with that to to this issue of
climate change resilience farmer is
coping with upcoming changes in the
climate and also mitigation what can
farms do to reduce their greenhouse gas
emissions that sequester carbon in soils
so this is a little cartoon showing all
the ups and downs of the three key
greenhouse gases affecting our climate
today which will focus on nitrous oxide
n2o methane seeds for of course co2 and
you've got the sole carbon piece there
and co2 coming out on the soil
um but of course a very important thing
about farms and this also applies to
natural vegetation and agroforestry is
there's the co2 uptake by the vegetation
and when you think about agriculture you
know today every industry is has some
level of concern about their their
carbon footprint right their greenhouse
gas emissions into the either public
relations issues and regulations
agriculture is highly unique perhaps
only compared to in forestry in terms of
we are an industry that can literally
suck co2 out of the atmosphere natural
geoengineering and so that's something
we talk to our farmers about that
actually you know this is an ecosystem
service but agriculture is playing and
how do we maximize that that co2 uptake
which can compensate for some greenhouse
gas emissions that are almost really
hard to completely eliminate it
agriculture system etc so we'll get into
some of that this is a slightly dated
pie chart but this is looking at the
basic trend is the same today this is
looking if you look at just kind of the
on-farm emissions on a co2 equivalent
basis the three key greenhouse gases
nitrous oxide steer tube and the methane
because nitrous oxide is almost three
hundred times more potent than carbon
dioxide on a molecule for molecule basis
in terms of its greenhouse gas warming
potential and methane is about 25 times
more potent you can see that when we
look at it on that sort of equivalent
basis the big culprit in terms of us and
this is true for many developing nations
that big culprit on the farm emissions
is nitrous oxide so so that's that's a
big storage for us before I go on so
let's talk about nitrous oxide for
example where does that nitrous oxide
being emitted from on farms who's a
bidding back on the farm well it's not
the easy one co2 where is there's some
co2 emissions on farm soil and who in
the soil is still emitting that microbes
agree everything it is not only microbes
earthworms everything that's aerobic and
respires in this law so either in macro
fauna and microbes um what else was
another emission of co2 animals got
animals breathing aerobic animals
tractor driving vehicles and that sort
of thing let's go to nitrous oxide
so who's emitting Booma in the farm is
emitting nitrous oxide I think we heard
of our tractors that much huh
so okay and who in the soil this is
almost exclusively microbes and actually
a few a small number of microbes really
just those involved in nitrogen cycle
the nitrifiers nitrified nitrifiers okay
methane whose emitting methane on the
farm animals like ruminant animals are
famous for this cows burping out methane
by who in the animals there's something
inside the animals that's living that
and that's microbes in there and anybody
know what those microbes are called that
releases methane methanogens so very
it's a large group of different species
by defendant almost all of this my point
is a large large fraction of this is
microbial action and co2 is while farms
are knitting co2 with the tractor
driving and etc that's not the big story
for agriculture in terms of you know in
terms of agricultural responsibility for
greenhouse gases in the atmosphere
there's a lot more co2 emitted by all of
us driving our cars and heating our
homes and all kinds of things the big
story for agriculture really is the
nitrous oxide and methane and much of
that happens in the soil really this is
also wet soils will release methane etc
so as I said if we were to talk about
you know what who's you know which
sectors of society are responsible for
co2 emissions it would mostly be
transportation of all kinds all
ourselves transporting ourselves around
industry etc agriculture would be a
small part of the co2 emissions globally
but when it comes to methane and nitrous
oxides here's the latest interview home
a lot of climate change report kind of
pie chart globally some of the major
sectors of society emitting those things
and maybe agriculture is not a minor
component of methane and nitrous oxide
emissions
we mentioned the ruminant animals that's
this 27% that's there are manages and
their guts these methanogens are
anaerobic so they methanogens they
basically breathe in carbon dioxide for
their oxygen for their electron
transport chain and they breathe out
methane so the anaerobic and this is why
why would then rice production anybody
figure out why rice production then is
part of a methane issue flooded soils
that are anaerobic low oxygen so there's
lots of methane emission from flooded
rice production of course there's new
ways of those ways of trying to reduce
the amount of flooding and rice
production a lot of people work on that
now and there's some other things as you
can see a big factor there also any kind
of any soil is flooded methanogens are
very ubiquitous I have regular farm
that's not growing in rice if it's
flooded for long periods of time there
can be some methane emissions and wet
animal maneuvers so you've got a dairy
barn and maybe you wash out the dairy
barn with lots of water and there's
urine and dry manure that goes somewhere
and it's soaking wet it's anaerobic just
a lot of methane emissions not just from
the cows that made the manure but now
from the wetland / nitrogen
fertilization you can see probably
already talked about this and we talked
about this in terms of the nitrogen
management and adapt in a little bit or
anything okay well roughly about 1% of
the nitrogen that goes into farm soils
for nitrogen fertilizer whether it's
manure organic source or whether it's
embedded connected to fertilizer bought
from a store about 1% of that is lost
into the atmosphere kind of a loss from
the system as the microbes break down
that nitrogen put it into forms that
boots can take up some of it is lost as
this gas nitrous oxide so the less
nitrogen
we put on the less nitrous oxide that is
worldwide of course we have to use some
nitrogen to produce our crops so we
can't eliminate that entirely but it is
another rationale for being very
judicious and careful about nitrogen
management on farms there's another
environmental quality issue we've been
talking about for many decades with
nitrogen management which is what
leaching of nitrate no3 a water soluble
form it's not a gas but nitrate leaching
so that's we've only been talking about
that for many years ago the water
quality it's another incentive for
farmers to be judicious about nitrogen
management basically is this new thing
we're recognizing about how crucial
agriculture is in terms of nitrous oxide
as the source of our climate change
moment we're having okay here's a here's
a sort of a little bit of the kind of
might say simple five chemistry of
what's happening with these three key
greenhouse gases and how it relates to
where they come from and gets into this
story of salt health and these stories
so we mentioned that there's co2
emissions as organic matter is
decomposed in soils you know as I said
earthworms can actually start this
process but also there's all kinds of
microbes that get involved fungi that
are all the kinds of aerobic organisms
so the decomposers the thick organic
matter in soil and break it down are
breathing in co2 and you can see in this
formula at the top the ch2oh
X is representing organic matter of all
types plus oxygen requires oxygen the
little arrow then shows where it goes
but that little arrow is microbial
mediated so those animals those microbes
eat the organic matter they grieve the
oxygens are
the respiration and they give off steel
too and that co2 goes back into the
atmosphere as carbon dioxide so now that
was organic matter that was storing
carbon in our soil but now it's going
back up into the atmosphere as the feed
house gas co2 so that's something to
think about we talked about reducing
tillage to keep organic matter in soils
right we've talked about that already
reducing tillage is one way to build up
organic matter
I have slow this process down and
sometimes just confusion people think
that well the tillage story the organic
matter is all about like breaking up
fungal hypha and there's mattress.you
and yes some of that's true but a big
thing about tillage its relationship to
building up organic matter in soils is
you don't over oxygenate the soil you
can see the more o2 we pump into the
soil such as any kind of tillage
operation the more you move things that
way and of course we do need our ganic
manner we do need some of it to be
broken down in terms of making the
nutrients that are contained in that
organic matter available to plants but
we don't want to go too fast and too
quickly that way because then the
organic matter disappears from our soil
faster than our plants can use the
products organic matter so that's why
tillage reducing tillage helps store
carbon in soils now let's look at the
nitrogen story this is a very simplified
cartoon version of what happens as we
have like organic matter biota it gets
converted by some of these microbes that
are involved and just fitting it into
the ammonia form so that I can go as a
volatile but someone who can also be
taking up a liquid form by plant roots
there's another bit of microbial
activity here that puts it into the
nitrate form that water soluble form and
we have to have some data
ammonia and nitrate form for plants to
take it out they don't take out plants
don't take up organic matter through
their roots they get their nitrogen
anyway so thank goodness we have these
microbes and do this or else it wouldn't
have recycling
nitrogen and nitrogen for our class but
you can see I have this NGO coming off
here and there and that's the loss
there's some losses in this system
volatile nitrous oxide goes off so the
more but newer you put on the field the
more you push it this way yes you get
more ammonium and nitrate that your
plants could take up good for you good
for the crop but you also get more
nitrous oxide emissions so yes you want
to put on enough manure or much enough
synthetic nitrogen it directly put on
ammonium or nitrate but for your crops
but you're gonna get the microbes doing
their thing here and you're going to get
some into Oh emissions and so we just
don't want to overdo it you've got to be
some of that fruit to grow crops I teach
you overdoing
I said roughly that varies very much
other details one percent on the
nitrogen supply as manure or ammonium
nitrate it's lost a siddhis so we're
gonna be very judicious one other thing
I wanna mention is this part here is an
aerobic process and denitrification is
where you get some of the biggest
interval losses and this is an anaerobic
flooded soils is where you get T
nitrification tosses around here in the
northeast I assume I don't know how many
of you are from the Northeast but a
place like the Northeast we have a time
of year when soils tend to be
particularly flooded anybody know where
that would be in terms of the Northeast
we get a lot of our nitrous oxide
emissions from denitrification spring
thaw the spring thaw we got me one of
the soils sometimes a third of
agricultural fields total annual nitrous
oxide emissions come off during the
spring thaw yeah so it also has a lot of
things to do with details of nitrogen
management we're not going to get into
today finally methane emissions all done
by the engines there are many different
species and the engines there are these
organisms that
bring in what we breathe out
but that oxygen is formed admittance
serves the same purpose as oxygen serves
for us as their electron transport team
temple ism and they breathe out bet
there any anaerobic environments and the
engines are all over the place and every
soil out here anywhere and in the guts
of animals the roommate animals
anaerobic wet soils and the Newars I
just subtracted room into animals all
those places natural wetlands give off
many natural wetlands because they are
totally so of course natural wetlands do
store a lot of carbon as a plant
material in a wetland Nashville wetland
dies and decomposes it goes to the
bottom and stays there because it's
anaerobic there that's not decomposed as
a lot of carbon kind of compensate a
carbon storage in wetlands on it
compensates a little bit for the methane
emissions but anyway all those
environments so this is this kind of so
you have kind of a little depth of
understanding about these three key
greenhouse gases that are happening in
our soils in our animals and
agricultural systems this quickly
another little you know a couple other
things to emphasize again in nitrogen
cycle and where that nitrous oxide
emissions stuff is coming from so we
have plant biomass we have decomposers
that begin to process degrading some of
that plant biomass starting with
earthworms and fungi than getting to
microbials that we have organic matter
which has nitrogen in it
we have microbes that will hit attack
that pretty quickly and turn it into
ammonium we have other and getting a
pipe roots to take that up we have
additional of two species of
microorganisms that can change the
ammonium to nitrate again plants can
take that up so that's all good kind of
recycling things but we didn't have
these losses from the system in this
process we can have some nitrous oxide
emissions as this process those odds of
microbes do this summer
goes up into the air as we have we have
an aerobics oils flooded soils we get
denitrification goes back up to into gas
but some is losses nitrous oxide and
then of course we talked about the
leaching of the actual nitrate so now
where do we get the nitrogen to keep
this whole thing going you got all these
nitrogen losses how do we keep we're
losing nitrogen here Suns going up
exporting harvest sun's going back of
the era's into leaching so how do we
keep our crops going huh nitrogen
fixation like having a legume crop up
there so either this itself is a
lightning providing some nitrogen to the
system to replenish it or we we have no
rotation with legumes what we actually
used synthetic nitrogen we use like some
kind of manure or an addition fertilizer
so but I wanted to point out about again
our carbon footprint of Agriculture and
this gets a little bit away from that
strictly solo part of it strictly Sobers
what I just was talking about all
nitrogen fertilizers give off nitrous
oxide as a potent greenhouse gas as they
degrade in so we can't get away from
that it only means let's be judicious
give them just what they need there's
another part of the carbon footprint if
you are not using manures but you are
using you're going and buying
synthetically manufactured nitrogen
fertilizers there can be four to six
tons of carbon dioxide emitted per ton
of nitrogen manufactured so if you're a
farmer and you don't want to mess around
with organic sources legumes and
rotation or you don't want to mess
health manure to go buy put a half way
about your synthetic nitrogen
fertilizers just by going to make that
purchase you have a carbon footprint
associated with the the the energy co2
emissions associated with that input
so that's another way to look at the
carbon footprint of farming systems
which I'm not going to spend a lot of
time with today because we're focusing
on soils but just to think about another
piece of the carbon footprint of
Agriculture is not just what happens
really on the farm with the soils and
the animals the rumen animals etc but
also there's the energy embedded in some
of the inputs so fertilizers if you look
at the story in terms of co2 emissions
and farms a lot of the co2 emissions
from farms are not talking this is not
talking about nitrous oxide emissions
this is the constant manufacturer of
fertilizers producing co2 so this is
fertilizer you bring into the farm from
somewhere else somewhere else there was
a lot of co2 paid for that it's a big
it's a big feature of the carbon
footprint of farms so something else to
think about when we think about the full
picture agriculture and climate change
this is why I haven't uploaded a pin yet
not really ok so well he'll be Nelson
others have been very involved over
years in developing a highly efficient
tool for forgetting at you know really
giving giving farmers good guidance
this is particularly focused on side
dressing corn with nitrogen making sure
you're giving them just what they need
and it takes account of for example by
taking weather data soil temperature
data how much of that natural soil
nitrogen cycle ins been going on and so
you're not providing there's been a lot
you've had warm spring for example with
warm soils you probably have more
nitrogen mineralization as services got
more kind of free nitrogen from soil you
could put on less fertilizer all of this
is about two dishes use so it's kind of
part of the soil health story and
reducing nitrous oxide emissions is
using new tools like this to be
judicious about that this is a sub data
from the farm up in Canada just showing
an
full of a mixed animal crop production
system is a dairy farm and here's
looking at some of the different types
of operations and aspects to the farm as
I mentioned co2 is considered these in
all of these calculations about co2
equivalents and greenhouse gas emissions
and we put everything on their co2
equivalent basis in a value of one so
there's some direct you know when you're
tilling the soil you're oxygenating the
soil stimulating microbial break down
organic matter and co2 goes up stop
there
the ruminants breathe out the animals
without co2 as well as beating out
methane and so so there's some co2 there
nitrous oxide excess nitrogen fertilizer
for timing place where all this nitrogen
management so they are the into o story
and methane we've got the ruminant
missions which we've all kind of famous
now and but also for manure management
that lead to methane emissions yeah what
one big there's a lot of strategies to
redo better manure management to reduce
methane emissions from manure management
also there's things about different
diets for ruminant animals to reduce
those but against a little bit off the
sole house story I'm not going to go
into that anything here is it's not all
about seeing - in tractor driving and
even it's not even about soil organic
matter decomposition
there's the other two gases are quite
important particularly mixed animal
production systems now recognize that
photo fans I show this photo when I go
to policy meetings in DC and see if they
can recognize hat I see that I see
carbon nitrogen and energy but we have
you know I used to teach today Matt Ryan
teaches a cropping systems ecology class
but I used to teach that and used to say
you know your people before you a lot of
people from Cornell
worked hard to because of the aspects of
production to scale etc decoupling
animal and crop production systems the
challenge today is recalling these
systems so we don't have a lot of manure
that just goes truly to waste and is
just a problem a water quality problem
etc and really thinking about using this
for energy for compost as we heard about
them and other things to regather that
stuff and there's a lot of work
Carol mention this too about we're
working hard to make sure these things
are getting recalled so so health so all
of these things that I've got down here
building so organic matter pretty key to
soil health reducing tillage I've
already kind of explained the
nitty-gritty of why that works so well
winter cover crops that's just you know
the more time we have in the year of
sucking co2 out of the atmosphere it's
good for reducing greenhouse gases in
the air and it's good for that's a lot
about co2 both ends up as organic matter
in the soil using the Newars of his
compost as we just heard about the
previous speaker I'll mention something
about biochar bring up crops all of
these increase organic matter that is a
adaptation to climate change farmers are
seeing more less predictable droughts
and flooding soils that are high in
organic matter tend to be bitter
draining and also in a flooding event
and also hold more water and so there
this helps build resilience to climate
change and by the way it's storing
carbon and install that otherwise would
be in the air steel too so farmers are
most of the years there's a big big
drive now for farms improve soil health
most of it much of it has to do if this
has tech though the resilience of farms
but there's also a lot of interest among
policymakers in terms of giving carbon
giving farmers so credit for what we're
doing for the ecosystem beyond the farm
and that has to do with the storing
carbon and soils so we already heard a
lot about compost so one way of course
is to literally add organic matter and
carbon to soils in terms of doing this
story of rebuilding salt health and also
storing carbon
soils it's usually if you you know if
you put on lots of compost you can
probably make the most difference most
quickly in terms of strategies compared
to reducing tillage or using cover crops
but fuel only some small-scale farmers
are doing what we call less deep compost
where you're literally putting on tons
and tons of compost on small plots you
can you can build a below attic matter
quickly but even doing it in more
reasonable amounts definitely helps
maintain organic matter in soils and is
part of the sole health story in terms
of claiming a positive thing that
agriculture does to compensate for
perhaps some of those inevitable
emissions that are just a part of like
any industry has some inevitable carbon
footprint to it in agriculture it's hard
to think of having a successful farmer
there's not some nitrous oxide emissions
due to nitrogen fertilizer I use some
methane emissions obviously if you are
using
ruminant livestock etcetera but we can
compensate for that by things like this
again other industries do not have ways
to really sequester carbon away and so
it's really unique about agriculture
very positive thing biochar has
everybody here who most of you heard
about biochar right have you talked
about that in it and of course at all
given oh yeah well so just to quickly
you and there's a person here Johan
exclaiming who's really are kind of one
of the international gurus on biochar
but I'll quickly say a couple things
about it essentially I think that ideal
angles of biochar is it's a way of
burning waste materials and turning them
into a sort of like a compost but
burning them in a special way earning
them any kind of us low low oxygen slow
burn type of process very low oxygen
environment and the end result is that
you get you get heat energy like we
would from burning wood
woodstove but with much less co2
emissions so first of all the actual
creation of biochar from waste is a way
to get energy by getting rid of waste
and a lot of BTUs a lot of energy for
universe co2 that goes up the atmosphere
most of the a lot of the carbon instead
of going up in the air atmospheric co2
typically is when you burn something in
a high oxygen environment a lot of the
states and so you end up with this kind
of a charcoal like material that's very
high in carbon in fact it's in Hertz the
entire carbon entirely carbon in a large
fraction of the carbon that was in the
original waste is still there the
interesting thing about this carbon is
even more than compost is the carbon
that's there is extremely stable
there's depends on the compost exactly
and it depends on different papers of
showing different stuff and it's hard to
know exactly but we're talking about you
put this material into a soil as carbon
and it's likely to stay there for 500
years it's not something it's not active
carbon its exact opposite of active
carbon that's one of the so lending
health indicators that's carbon that's
really readily available to the snow
microbial food rather it's really good
for feeding the microbes that you want
to benefit stop by a car is not gonna
feed the microbial food web but it has a
couple features with it first of all it
is storing away carbon for a long time
so a lot of policymakers are really high
on this thinking we can let's take all
of our waste and turn into biochar we'll
bury it in there all this excess co2 in
the atmosphere will bury it in our soils
but what it does for soil is a couple
things um it is just carbon some people
think it's like a magic thing you put in
there and plants grow faster no it's
just card by itself but it has a high
cation exchange capacity like clays that
you miss - so nutrients in the soil can
attach to it or you can nutrient and
rich it before you that's just pure
biochar on there but nutrient rich if
for example yohannes is looking into a
system of taking manure waste and
nutrient enriching it enriching biochar
with manure waste and then putting it in
the soil then you had some
is actually convinced the other thing
that two of the things that are
beneficial biochar and soil is um it
does help improve somewhat cell
structure water holding capacity and
such and and drainage and there's been
some studies showing it creates a neat
habitat for beneficial soil microbes
like Michael Rises so so it's a very
easy thing that the cutting edge sort of
it's not really broadly available but
here at Cornell Thomas has a very big
pyrolysis unit which is kind of a very
sophisticated way to make biochar and
something coming kind of coming down the
pike and something to do on the surface
it's very fine yeah that can be seen as
it can it can it can attract nuisance
that could be carried away so if you put
balance our isn't it best incorporated
in the soil where it is not available
and although again you know then you're
killing and you're losing a little
organic matter but you're saying end up
with high nutrient status and very upper
profile so developer rotation
okay so finally I think I just five
minutes left I want to get through this
last series of things in which these two
things are so health and greenhouse gas
mitigation are mixed so first of all
sustaining healthy productive soils we
visas is a land for land clearing
deforestation for for new production so
this is a big issue for developing
countries where there's a lot of shallow
soils of some of these tropical soils
that aren't well managed and then you
end up having to keep clearing new land
so working hard in developing nations to
reduce deforestation and all that has to
do with me
healthy soils because that's a lot about
11% of annual human co2 emissions are
supposed to the deforestation where's
Carter than those those trees and it
goes up in the air as they decompose
healthy soils have better drainage
therefore they're not going to be
anaerobic they're going to be less prone
to be flooded and anaerobic so you end
up with fewer nitrous oxide emissions
and fewer methane emissions I maintain a
year-round vegetation cover obviously is
pumping capturing co2 from the
atmosphere something you want to do for
soil health and organic matter build-up
anyway
maximize reliance on end fixation legen
cover crops for crop needs improves
nitrogen use efficiency and reduces
dioxide emissions so the more you're
using legumes and that sort of thing in
terms of building up salt health the
more you are reducing having to go buy
synthetic nitrogen fertilizers healthy
soils require fewer chemical inputs in
general a lot of farmers are finding
this out and all of those chemicals
whether they be a pesticide or synthetic
fertilizer took energy to produce there
were co2 emissions somewhere to produce
them so fewer chemical inputs with
healthy soils less manufactured
transport costs etc reducing tillage
frequency first of all we do sit the
fossil fuel emissions with running the
tractors around to fill the soil it's
good no co2 emissions associated with
that and of course we know it tends to
leave more of the organic matter carbon
in the soil upper so profile at least so
I've got a few things on biofuel crops
that's another angle and so instead of
you know is this kind of alternatively
in terms of using energy that you're
getting from a power plant which is
maybe burning coal or something using
biofuel crops has its advantages that
does depend on how you grow the crops
that you use a lot of fossil fuel energy
to produce the biofuel crops that
obviously doesn't work but if you're
using minimal inputs to produce biofuel
crops are neat alternative and so amount
of time that right
yeah okay there's some constraints to
mitigation concerns about costs and
risks of mitigation pharma may want to
use wind turbines or reduce their
nitrogen fertilizer but they're
concerned about the risk imitation
confuse yields concerns about more labor
as it's going backward doing things the
old-fashioned way sometimes there's just
enough policy incentives or actual
constraints farmers doing some of these
practices farmers are concerned if we
start paying attention to this and doing
more to reduce our greenhouse gas
emissions and make a big deal about how
we're doing all this good stuff for
climate change is you know some
government agency can start coming out
and measuring our nitrous oxide
emissions that difficulties in
quantifying the mitigation benefits so
for example my student that was
mentioned who's done a lot of infrared
spectroscopy work and carbon has also
looked at how can we monitor soils more
cheaply to look at the carbon change and
there's this plant neutral so low
nutrients hosting process results in a
low nitrogen which is Muslim so using
ellika relying a lot on compost which
Peter speaker focused on can end up with
kind
lower nitrogen lower nitrogen situation
yeah so I think well I mean maybe the
compost person should address that our
previous speaker I would just say I mean
there that can't be the case was it
depends on the nature of the compost
you're using and how that nitrogen
phosphorus and other carbon nitrogen
balances and all that but yes you might
have to consider amending us off with
other other sources of nitrogen that you
know more fresh manure or actual types
of synthetic nitrogen fertilizer so
maybe give any other comments about
long-term compost use that might be low
in nitrogen leading to a nitrogen it's
not enough nitrogen to really use it in
conjunction with the nitrogen fixers and
and or other types of amendments or
literally other you know urea or morning
nitrate or something like that up slowly
is lasers how they would compare with
compost
well the slow release fertilizers yeah
so I mean I think that's another angle
to reducing nitrous oxide emissions can
be the you know the slow release things
you might add the nitrogen fertilizers
or different types of nitrogen
fertilizer sources release the nitrogen
at different rates that can better match
the needs of the crop as the plant grows
and so that is a good thing in terms of
moving farmers away from just pouring on
lots of nitrogen a lot frequently
repeatedly to make sure the crops not
going to be you know missing any
nitrogen and that that can lead to
excessive nitrogen applications in max
oxide emission so slow release nitrogen
when when appropriately done in taking
advantage of all it offers can reduce
nitrous oxide emissions yeah so that's
not alternative
I was working can I grow beans soybeans
and one of the things that we were doing
there is they did as far as killing
lunch they did make burrows and we might
grow those we were looking at different
amendments including biochars and
compost and fertilizers and all that
kinda stuff and the compost and the
biochar were were micro dose into the
firm so they were right where the seed
would be able to use you know we're
we're pretty good right at the site when
things were needed and that was an
interesting way to the plant is because
I know I've been a bit of you know it
you know work with farms we were using
compost and it's amazing you're putting
on tons and you want to look at it it's
like a fine little you barely see it
right but we do in these farmers now
there's where there's D compost thing I
have to talk to you separately about
this at some point but they're putting
on Regan it's like that you know it's
like wow okay yeah any other last
question before you guys get the break
okay thanks this has been a production
of Cornell University on the web at
Cornell edu